what's going on everyone happy whatever
day it is that you are watching this
um i get messages all the time all the
time
um and comments about what are your
favorite books and maybe in another
video or podcast i will
do uh do an exploratory you know what i
mean of the the books that have been
most influential
but if i'm being honest uh i didn't
really start reading a ton until after i
had made a lot a lot of
you know a relatively high amount of
money right
and uh and i started reading when i had
more time right so
so it would be kind of backwards for me
to say hey these are the things that
created my success when in reality i
feel like i
started reading when i had the time and
be like ah this is really interesting
and so um i think that to to kind of
make this story full circle before i
even started my first business
i was definitely a seeker uh which is
like you're just
looking for something you're searching
for something that's because you just
realize that something's wrong with your
life right
and that's kind of how i felt when i had
my my consulting job which is what i
took after college
and during that time period i read all
the time
and i remember realizing after six or 12
months of just reading book after book
after book of self-help and
you know personal development and like
all that kind of stuff that
my life was literally the same and i
remember this was like kind of like a
jarring moment for me because i just sat
there i finished a book and then i
thought to myself and it was like the
happiness advantage or some you know
whatever right
and i was like uh my life
is not any different than it was before
i started reading these books
and so i thought about it for a while
and i also realized that
half the books contradicted each other
and i was like man this is really
difficult
and so what i ended up my conclusion was
i wouldn't read a book unless i executed
everything in the book
and so what ended up happening next was
i became very very selective about what
books i would read because i would
i wouldn't get another book until i have
felt like i had executed that
and so the result of that was instead of
reading lots of books i started reading
a handful of books a lot of times and so
that was
um really transformational for me i
think the first book that i read a lot
of times was how to make friends and
influence people
and i still think to this day if you
just did nothing else in business but
just practiced what is in that book
you would be phenomenally successful
like it's you know to me like if you
just did the things that are in that
book you'd be phenomenally successful
um but that's kind of more like personal
you know personal traits and character
traits and whatnot which i think are
very important for
you know growing developing but in terms
of skills right and i would say the
number one
you know number one and number two
things that i get asked about are like
hey how did you develop your skill of
marketing and how did you develop your
scale of sales
and truth be told i never did a single
sales training
um i never read a single sales book uh
before i started selling
and so that's i wish i had like a really
sexy answer for you but i don't um
i just started selling and i didn't even
know that what i was doing
was selling i was just like how do i get
people to sign up for my gym and give me
money like i didn't even know that term
was sales at the time i was just like i
have to get them to give me money
and so um i think a lot of people spend
way too much time in the like the
liberation stage and like they're trying
to
there you spend all your effort in the i
would say like productive
procrastination space
of just like thinking you're getting
better but you would get so much better
just doing it
right and so only like and people now
respect what i have to say about sales
because i've sold so much not because of
how many books i've read on sales right
and so um i think that once i was
considered
very good at sales i had you know i was
managing multiple sales teams and we
were doing you know a few hundred
thousand dollars a month
that is the first time i bought a sales
product like think about that
and i went through it i was like oh this
is good stuff you know like there's
there's stuff in here that
we can use like neat but like i don't
think it fundamentally changed how good
i was at selling
um and i think that that's because so
much of selling is about conviction it's
about how much you believe in the
product
more so than like the the judo chops
right it's about how much you care about
the prospect and how much you hear about
the pro and convince that the product
will help them because if you truly talk
from a space of genuine care like
genuine care about a prospect
you won't convince them to do something
that they shouldn't do and if you
genuinely believe that your product or
service
is going to help people then making the
sales very easy because it's like i
really care about you and i really know
that this product works and so let me
just like help you connect these two
dots
and so that's like ultimately like that
is what selling is and should be
the problem is most people don't believe
in their product and they don't care
about their prospects
right and so because of that they come
into all this cognitive dissonance
meaning like they believe themselves to
be good people but at the same time they
need to make money and then those two
things
become at odds and that becomes really
difficult to sell because now you're
you're faced with a moral obligation um
to like your family
you know to try and provide and then
against yourself to be ethical right and
that becomes really hard for people
that's why a lot of sales guys get
burned out when they find out more about
whatever they're selling
and so that's why a lot of times sales
guys will start start out hot and then
crash just because they find out what
they were selling with the
what they were sold to sell is actually
not what it really is cracked up to be
and then once they find that out then
all of a sudden
um that's that's why in my belief
there's way more churn in sales people
than would otherwise be necessary if
they were all selling something they
believed in
right so back to the main point which is
what do i do if i don't
like if i have no way of you know
practicing well
i mean honestly when i when i want to do
something what i do is i buy a course
about how to do something
and then i follow the course and do it
so if i wanted to make a webinar
then i bought a course on making webinar
and then i followed the course to make
the webinar and so i learned the skill
while i was going through the course i
don't think there's a lot of productive
time and usage in in learning stuff
for the sake of learning like it's like
and i don't even i would even make the
argument that you don't even truly learn
it
until you've applied it and so like
how do you know if you read six books on
sales and they have different strategies
which one is
is the right one because you've never
tested it in the battlefield right it
doesn't make any sense
and so um like the same thing with
marketing i never i never bought a
copywriting course
i never bought any courses on how to
build landing pages i never bought any
courses on how to run ads
the only thing i did was i spent um i
spent money one on one to get someone to
train me literally how to click to run
ads for my gym
but i learned a little bit i learned
enough on my own and so that's the thing
is like
i think there's definitely a space for
one-on-one training i think the biggest
gains i've made
have been from investing in people who
are above me to break my beliefs about
what was possible
because the people were above you most
of times are not going to like
they're not going to hold your hand and
teach you how to write copy this is not
going to happen
i mean like they might edit you know
copy you have if you have like a
one-on-one relationship something like
that but
for the most part like it's going to be
up to you to go acquire those skills and
most of the time
acquiring those skills comes from doing
them which means you're going to suck
for a while and i think just most people
aren't aren't willing to try because
they think that if they are perfect
they'll somehow not fail the first time
which is stupid because even when you're
really good you're going to fail
so it's just people like procrastinating
and reading books about something that
they haven't done
is a productive way of feeling
accomplished without actually doing
anything
and so um i say all this to say for the
many people who
who ask me what are my favorite books on
sales and marketing my favorite book on
sales is to get out there and start
selling
right because if you start selling and
then read a book on sales it will make
far more sense to you than trying to
read a book on sales before you start
selling
because you won't even know what they're
talking about right same thing with
marketing
right like if you if you want to go and
learn about marketing the best thing to
do is start
you know learn how to run an ad you run
an ad to a landing page
and then start getting some people who
give you their contact information and
then pick up the phone and call them
like you know what i mean and the
easiest thing to do in my opinion is the
advice that i got from ezra firestone
years ago
which is give yourself a slush fund
right give yourself a learning budget
which is how much am i willing to quote
blow this month
on failure so i can learn the skills
faster and whatever that percentage is
might be ten percent of what you make
every month maybe five percent it might
be 25
it just depends on who you are and how
stable your income is but if you just
say i'm willing to give 500
a month to learning the skill then you
don't have this like emotional
attachment to whether or not you crush
it your first time because
you're seeing this 500 a month
investment
is truly that an investment in your
education your investment in trial and
error
rather than uh you know like i bought
this question copywriting i'm not a
millionaire what's wrong
right when in reality you just have to
get out there and start doing it so um
anywho that's my that is my two cents i
i made most of my money before i started
reading a lot of books i would say
like seriously i read maybe 30 books
before we
you know were deca millionaires you know
what i mean um
and so i wish i had something better for
you but i
i focus most of my time on doing and
applying and when i start applying
then i will go read for specific
solutions to a bottleneck that i have
rather than trying to learn an amorphous
topic
by reading words from multiple books and
trying to get perspectives
different angles on problems i've never
even encountered yet
right i think it's much better to
encounter the problems
than start seeking the solutions than
trying to cover every solution
to every problem before you've even
started the race so anyways hope you
found that valuable hope that made sense
lots of love keeping awesome and i'll
catch you guys soon bye